[Music]
what tips can we use to break the spirit
of procrastination
and prepare for christ during this
probationary period
we can live our lives the way look at
the rhythm of god's operation when he
created
genesis chapter 1 verse 5 and the
evening in the morning with the first
day look at verse 8 even in the morning
with the second day you look at the god
function one day at a time are you
following me that's the way we ought to
live because we do not know anything
about tomorrow we should live one day at
a time we should live with a sense of
urgency a sense of purpose a sense of
god's desire for us that's how we ought
to live one day at a time we ought to
live with our minds our hearts in the
word of god because the word is a lamp
into our feet a light onto our path we
shall make choices in the light of the
fact we're living in the last days now
there might have been a different
attitude in the days of abraham because
abraham was thousands of years removed
from the close of probation on a global
scale he was thousands of years removed
from october 23 1844 even paul was but
we are literally
on the doorstep of return of jesus
christ and so our lives ought to reflect
a sense of urgency that perhaps has
never been seen before and that urgency
means we need to ask what is really
important and the important thing that
should stand before everyone's eye is
the preparation to receive christ even
if my i close my eyes in death today am
i ready to receive my savior and this is
the way we ought to live we ought to
stay in god's word we ought to stay in
the testimonies of ellen white that
special instruction sent to god's people
and we ought to do what we can to
enlighten others so that our whole life
suggests that we're focusing on the
return of christ and a preparation to
meet our savior when he comes
amen amen one day at a time
i was reading councils to parents
teachers and students a while back
by ellen white and she was talking about
a man that was very productive and
everybody wondered how did he get
everything done and he told them
simple i do one thing at a time that's
right
i do one thing at a time and it's crazy
because even at my school
we have uh sessions on how we should
study and how we can you know put in our
hours and there is a technique called
the pomodoro technique
what is it you take 25 minutes of
focused time where you accomplish one
task so you work on one task and then
you take some time to take a break
taking one day at a time one task at a
time one at the time
so then we're not worried about what the
next step will be because we are present
with jesus uh the miracle of turning
water to wine when the mother said they
have no wine christ said woman what if i
to do with thee my hour is not yet come
in other words it's not the time for
this it's time for something else now in
john 17 he says father the hour is come
and so christ lived is like this is a
time for that this is a time for that
and he did not do things out of time
you see he did not everybody said he
woke up every day and asked god what
should he do he was that close to his
father and we ought to try to be that
close to god and so
living in the moment as you said today
is all i have
this hour is all i have what can i do to
get closer to my savior because you
cannot get too close to god
amen amen
lucifer was close to god and look at
what happened to him
you can't get in close to god and
lucifer and he fell
mystery of mysteries and mystery of
negativity so we need to keep clinging
clinging clinging with a consciousness
to our savior
you